good to see you nate all right let's
have some fun uh we're gonna learn a
little bit more
about alex first of all we're playing
two truths and one lie
yes so give us the three things the
three options there will be two that are
true and one that is
a lie right yes okay yours are all right
kendall you ready i'm ready so number
one my dad
walked me through a jail when i was a
kid to set me straight
oh it was like a scared straight thing
yeah he was a sheriff's deputy okay
two i used to be a sunday school teacher
okay
three i auditioned to be a disney
princess
at disneyland okay so as we digest these
put these back up on the screen we want
to study these and look at these
because i i want to tell you the one
that jumps out at me
as like wow this has to be true is that
you audition to be a disney princess
because you kind of had that vibe right
ah
no it's very i mean that is a compliment
so i would say that's the lie
because i think your dad probably did
try to scare you straight and that you
did teach sunday school at one time that
is right that's true
i'm way too short to be a disney
princess
but thank you that's very good kendall
all right all right so let's get to
kendall's now let's get those on the
screen
okay so uh only what no two of these are
true one's alive are they
i ate a dozen live crickets for charity
uh
the ending of monsters inc makes me cry
or and i was a qb of my high school
football team
okay in texas you didn't live in texas
yeah i do believe that
okay okay end of monsters inc makes you
cry
ate a dozen live crickets see i believe
you ate crickets but maybe it wasn't a
dozen like it could have been
oh you think i'm just a little curveball
curveball
uh i'm gonna say eight a dozen live
crickets is the lie
that is the truth that is true i did
thanks to uh mercedes and jc they had a
contest oh that's horrible you had a
dozen
a dozen live they're supposed to be our
friends i know right yeah
yeah uh i was not the qb of my high
school football team
i played football but i had no skills um
my coach once said i couldn't catch a
cold
oh so yeah there you go they stuck me on
defense
where i didn't have to actually catch
them okay okay yeah we'll shoot i
believed them all
kendall very convincing well yours were
good as well all right
i think we have more oh we have more
yeah okay i have three more for you are
you ready wow this is good
okay bonus round bonus round okay
kendall we did not rent an apartment
because i could tell it was haunted i
can speak french
i can test you on this one i skipped
second grade
i have no comment you
[Laughter]
let's show them on the screen again let
me see them on the screen i do believe
that you skipped
uh an apartment because you felt it was
haunted
ah between these two you're under twa
was pretty convincing
so i'll go with you skip the second
grade i did skip second grade
i do not speak french i wish i did
it you know was pretty good did you
understand anything i was saying to you
uh a little bit so you do speak a little
bit
my family is a syrian and their family
speaks some french
okay so i've been around it picked up
something i've done all the apps and i
just can't remember it so i'll just
speak it with you
okay okay maybe i can get somewhere
finally
we're gonna be right back more quizzes
by the way